&gt;&gt; For this problem, we start with our slope formula. And, we already know the
slope, it's 1 4th. We also want to fix one of these points to be x and y, and
then this other point will be x 1 y 1. So I have the slope is 1 4th, I fix the
point x,y, and then this last point is 6 negative 1. So 6 for the x, negative 1
for the y. After substituting the values, here's the equation I get. You can
think about cross multiplying here, or just multiplying by the least common
denominator, which would be 4 times x minus 6. The 4 is reduced to 1, and the x
minus 6, and the x minus 6 also reduced to 1. 1 times x minus 6, is well, just x
minus 6. And then, I have 4 times the quantity y plus 1. So I need to distribute
this four to both terms. So 4 y plus 4. I want to write this equation in
standard form, like this. So I need to move this constant to the right and the 4
y to the left. I'm going to add 6 to both sides to get a constant on the right
so I get x equals 4 y plus 10. And now I subtract 4 y from each side. So I get x
minus 4 y equals 10. I just list these terms here because they are not like. If
you got x minus 4 y equals 10, amazing work. I know this isn't the easiest
problem and we haven't even covered how to do this part here. So, if you got it,
excellent work.